theater also you have to understand a
lot of this is just theater There Is No
Business Like Show Business okay so here
is CNN's Alex marquad he was on uh he
was in Kiev when when Biden showed up a
day or two ago and if you want to know
what theater it is sometimes they even
have to show you on CNN
um I've been here for the past five days
I have not heard any explosions I have
not heard any air Sirens until about
half an hour ago right when uh President
Biden was in the center of Kiev as
Clarissa was was just mentioning isn't
that wild isn't that wild no bombs no
Sirens no nothing then the president
shows up and oh my God just as he's
walking out into the city center to meet
the guy he's given all the cash too
there's there's bomb alerts and there's
sirens and everything and it's theater
you know it is 100 theater because
nobody ran towards buy it into a bombs
coming cover them up you know you at
least put your hand up or an umbrella or
something nobody did that they did it so
that you would hear sirens in the
background again so you would subtly
what you would be seeing and hearing
would be disconnected from reality and
you wouldn't know what to make of it why
do you think we would send our president
whether it was Ronald Reagan or Joe
Biden or Bill Clinton or George should
be wish do you think we send him to a
war zone where there is any threat
whatsoever of him being bombed no there
isn't and even on freaking CNN they had
to admit it
[Music]